willkommen zu einem neuen video seht ihr
ein gameplay von mir auf 7 glaube ich
ein richtig gutes gameplay da waren echt
ein paar coole szenen dabei und ein sehr
sehr sehr spannendes finale hat mir
persönlich gut gefallen
checkt das gerne mal ab und bildet euch
gefällt werden lawson wie immer ein
daumen das sind da einfach abschalten
lassen da ist kein ding so oder mal zum
thema als allererstes würde ich gerne
mal bitten dass hier mal eure meinung in
die kommentare schreibt ich habe die
ganze geschichte mit dem mikrofon so ein
bisschen umgebaut und zwar ist der
mikrofonarm jetzt nicht mehr hinter dem
bildschirm da hinten und reicht das
mikrofon über den bildschirm sondern es
eher rechts neben mir und gibt mir das
seitlich an finde das cool ist das sound
besser sieht's besser schlechter aus
schreibt das gerne meine kommentare
unabhängig davon werde ich dann
entscheiden ob wir zum alten
zurückkehren oder das beibehaltene so
delay leute jetzt zum thema des heutigen
tages das 50.000 special dazu möchte ich
euch heute einiges erzählen und mir
alles möchte ich alles zu erzählen alles
zu 50.000 arbeitsplätze leute kriegt ihr
alle infos von mir
es wird ein bisschen anders sein aber
dazu erstmal noch eine kurze
vorgeschichte und zwar mein bester
kumpel der mit mir studiert schaut auch
mal ein youtube videos und gebt mir da
immer ab und zu mal ein paar tipps
grüßen dich adrian wenn du das siehst
und er meinte so ja es gibt ja so diese
specials auf youtube wenn die leute
irgendwo marke erreichen
nehmen sie das zum anlass sich in
irgendeiner form zu bedanken
allerdings sind diese specials irgendwie
nicht nicht fassbar dass man den leuten
zurück man sagt irgendwie danke in dem
man sich länger hin setzt ein video
produziert aber leute kriegen nichts
fassbares zurück und werden auf dieser
internet eben das will ich gerne ändern
und deswegen wird 59.000 euro special
darin bestehen dass fünf zuschauer 5g 25
11 23 45 leute die gelegenheit bekommen
einen tag um ihr zu verbringen
einfach mal so und zwar nicht
irgendeines sondern einen besonderen tag
welche tag wird er sein direkt die info
vorneweg der 28 juni sonntag nächster
woche genau in einer woche
dieses video am sonntag auf wenn es am
sonntag seht ist es in einer woche wenn
es mal anders sieht ist es dennoch der
28 juni ein sonntag wo in stuttgart und
was passiert da an diesem tag findet ein
pre testing event statt wie man das
nennt diese speed racing event heißt
dass mein eigener bürger der essen sind
es da verköstigt wird und alle leute die
an diesem tag da sind den bürger ich
glaube kostenlos probieren können
ich bin ich hundertprozentig sicher aber
auf jeden fall wird es da wohl eine
möglichkeit geben den zu bekommen sonst
würde ich ja nicht wie testing event
heißen tee ist im sinne von schmecken
dazu möchte ich euch gerne einladen 5
von euch weil ich mal ein abo special
machen möchte was bisschen anders ist
nichts langweiliges nichts in form von
dem video sondern was was euch zuschauer
auch als menschen wertschätzt denn ich
finde das für oftmals nicht statt die
zuschauer werden irgendwie so als wenn
sie die zahlen meines kommt auch dadurch
dass man so viele zuschauer hat dann
alles ist größere youtuber das ist keine
ahnung
700.000 aufrufe im monat sind oder so
unter den einzigen den einzelnen
menschen noch so würdigen fällt schwer
und dann auf der gamescom auf dem video
das haben die zuschauer irgendwie 30
sekunden zeiten stehen dafür stundenlang
an
das finde ich ein bisschen doof ehrlich
gesagt und das möchte ich persönlich
ändern
deswegen gebe ich fünf von euch die
möglichkeit da einen nachmittag mit mir
zu verbringen ganzen nachmittag so dass
man auch wirklich ein bisschen bisschen
zeit hat so soweit die angelegenheit
dann kommen wir doch gleich mal dazu wie
man sich dafür bewirbt weil die fünf
leute müssen irgendwie ausgewählt werden
bevor ihr euch bewerben möchte ich
darauf hinweisen dass es unbedingt
wichtig ist dass ihr vor mit euren
eltern oder mit sonstigen personen das
zu entscheiden haben abklärt ob ihr am
in stuttgart sein könnt und zwar um von
14 30 bis 14 30 bis 16 uhr
und es ist wichtig dass auch dabei sein
können nämlich dass dann jemand
angenommen wird der am ende gar keine
zeit hat man so nah
ich kann doch nicht einfach verboten im
letzten moment also klärt das bitte
vorher mit euren eltern ab ist ganz
wichtig dann jetzt zum thema bewertet
wie machen wir es ich habe mir ein paar
gedanken gemacht bisschen hin und her
gedriftet nicht entscheiden konnte
welche methode der auswahl ich dann am
ende wählen möchte ich habe mich jetzt
dafür entschieden dass wir das einfach
direkt unter diesem video machen und
alle leute die gerne teilnehmen möchten
mit dem hashtag stuttgart 28
unter diesem video kommentieren und zwar
mit einem kommentar in dem er kurz
schildert oder auch länger wie ihr lust
habt warum ihr am 28 dabei sein sollte
warum gerade ihr warum nicht immer
anders nein warum gerade ihr können
einfach warum ihr dabei sein sollte nich
warum die andern nicht dabei sein sollen
schreibt einfach rein seid kreativ
lustig witzig die emotional schräg
verrückt irgendwie irgendwas rein was
was was cool ist was interessant ist
ich werde die besten 5 kommentare dann
auswählen und kontaktieren die deadline
für die bewerbung ist mittwoch der 24
um 24 uhr das kann man sich gut merken
hier weil er dann im laufe des nächsten
tages kontaktiert werden
dann sage ich hey ich hab dich
ausgewählt dabei zu sein steht es noch
und so weiter und so fort
und dann kriegt ihr noch weitere infos
von ihren mit der adresse bepo und dann
kann es schon losgehen leute das ist
glaube ich alles was ich zu dem thema zu
sagen habe fassen wir noch mal zusammen
bewerbung bis zum 24 24 uhr
das event findet in stuttgart statt
sonntag der 28
um 14.30 abklären dass ihr dasein könnt
bevor und bewerbt und schlussendlich
geht es darum ein bisschen zeit mit ihm
zu verbringen und eine burger kritiken
zu machen und keine ahnung was da so
passiert weiß ich auch nicht ganz genau
ja das waren die infos von meiner seite
jetzt an die tasten für euch schreibt
gerne was unter dieses video wenn ihr
wenn ihr bock wenn ihr lust habt die
besten fünf werden ausgewählt wie gesagt
von mir
die nicht die beste aber die die mir am
besten gefallen das war es von meiner
seite denkt noch mal an den kommentar
zum setup ihr ich hoffe das gameplay im
hintergrund euch auch gefallen dass wir
jetzt wissen schneller laufen weil es
ungefähr dreimal so lange dauert wie
meine ansage hier aber das ist glaube
ich auch könig für euch lassen daumen
nach oben da wir sehen uns beim nächsten
video wieder haut rein macht es gut und